[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Give me
one minute, and I'll
tell you how Cloud Data
Loss Prevention can
help you detect and
protect sensitive data
across your systems.
Cloud Data Loss
Prevention, or Cloud DLP,
is a fully managed service that
lets you discover, classify,
and protect all kinds
of sensitive data
from various sources.
Cloud DLP can recognize
up to 150 different data
types like names, addresses,
dates, credit card, numbers
and more.
You can even define your
own custom info types
based on custom
dictionary detectors
or regular expressions.
Every sensitive
value that DLP finds
is assigned a certainty
score, ranging
from very unlikely
to very likely,
giving you the flexibility
to set a confidence
threshold for inspections
and de-identification jobs.
Speaking of de-identification,
the Cloud DLP API
offers a number of
de-identification techniques
to obscure, mask,
tokenize, or transform
those sensitive values in
your data based on the info
type and the likelihood score.
With Cloud DLP, you
can send data directly
into the API or
schedule inspection
jobs that will scan
the data that you
specify for sensitive values.
So you can regularly gain
visibility into the data
that you store and process.
Cloud DLP has built-in support
for scanning and classifying
data from Cloud
Storage and BigQuery
and has a streaming
content API and hybrid
API so that you can
scan other data sources,
or so you can use it as
part of custom workloads
and applications.
The API even leverages
optical character recognition
to scan images for
sensitive data,
allowing you to
detect and redact
that data from image files.
So next time you're looking to
detect, classify, and secure
your sensitive data, take a
minute to look at Cloud Data
Loss Prevention.
To learn more check out
cloud.google.com/dlp.